hey what's up on today's show i talked
to a 19 year old guy who found
quote unquote the one he wants some
advice and i give him some
we also talk to a woman who's got a kid
and a husband
who has a kid by another mom and another
kid by another mom
things get messy when he has an affair
and finally i talked to an
incredible mom and wife whose husband
was just diagnosed with cancer
and she wants to know some tactics and
some strategies for telling her autistic
child what's going on
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up hope everybody's
doing good this is delony welcome to the
dr john daloni show
the show where we take real calls from
real people it's not scripted
it's not pretend it's not fake it's real
people struggling with real issues real
things going on in their hearts and
their minds the good stuff
the bad stuff the cuts and the bruises
the skin knees reaching a hand down and
pick each other up
helping each other dust off and then
making the next right move so
if you're new to our our our gang here
dude we talk about
everything on this show mental health
issues relationship issues marriage
issues
addiction parenting anything anything
you can think of give me a call
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291 or
you can go to
the uh i'm not gonna do it they told me
there is no more ww anymore
said uh old man so you go to
johndaloni.com nope forget it
go to www.johndaloney.com
you forgot the https
you're going to go to http colon slashes
www.johndaloney.com
show fill out the form
i would prefer if you could just send a
letter in on a yellow pad
uh write a no a letter and mail it to us
but um www.johndelene.com
show is much faster now i'm just doing
it on accident i can't help it now
so um so i get this question a lot and i
want to just address this right begin
the show
um folks ask a lot how can i
better connect with my kids like i'm
always telling people to touch your kids
on the face i'm always telling them to
you know play with their kids interact
with their kids and folks ask
a lot how do you do that how do you
practice that
and so here is a a
page out of the child play therapy book
this something that was transformative
for me as a kid
and dr janet freshly dr janet freshly
hicks
taught me this and she was she's a
maestro
at child therapy and it it paid
significant dividends in my life with my
kids and then it helped me become a
better husband and then it
helped me become a better employee
because it just changed the way i
interact with people
um most of the time i would get down on
all fours
or on the floor and try to be a good dad
that way play with my kids number one
you got to get down on the floor and
play with your kids
if you got kids who are teenagers this
won't work if i'm talking to folks with
kids who are maybe 10
11 12 and younger 10 11 12 is getting a
little bit old but let's try it let's
let's cap it at 10. you get down on the
floor to play with your kids
and what i turned those into inevitably
were
lessons i would say hey you know you can
do this with your legos or
um why don't you make the horse do this
or why don't you
and i would try to direct the play for
these kids
and i felt good about myself because i
was on the floor in the in all
it was good right i'm putting my kids
but what i
i teach kids behind my messaging is
whenever dad shows up whenever somebody
else shows up
the way they want to do things is the
best and you should just
do whatever they want to do and i rob my
children from the opportunity to a
learn to use their voice learn to use
their imagination but more importantly
i let them know that their job when we
interact is to see me not the other way
around and so what play therapy does is
it teaches a kid
how to be seen how to be heard
and it teaches the parent how to listen
and so there's this this activity that a
therapist will do called tracking
and here is all it is and it's hard to
do you got to practice it
but you get down on the floor with your
five-year-old your six-year-old your
three-year-old your two-year-old your 10
year old
and you just follow them and you say
things like
you are picking up that car wow you are
driving that car really fast
you are riding that horse all the way
across your room oh you just jumped that
horse over
your bed and here's the thing that's it
no questions
no advice no invitations no
what if we nope you just track the
child's movements with their toys
and eventually the child will tell a
story with their toys because children
speak through play and what it does over
time and it usually happens
really quickly like 10 minutes 15
minutes 20 minutes
is they may look at you kind of weird
like what are you doing and you just let
them know
i'm just listening because i love
listening to you i love being here
with you and then you go right back to
tracking them ask no questions
give no directions just track them and
you will watch them
come alive and it's really remarkable
and then if you do that to your wife or
your husband they're going to call the
police
on you and you're going to be
institutionalized so don't track your
family members as they're older
but it does over time teach you how to
sit and listen to somebody
and be engaged and watch them do what
they're doing so
instead of sitting there listening for
my turn to speak
instead of listening to my wife for my
chance to jump in with my advice
i watch her talk i listen to her talk
what is she actually saying what's her
whole body
saying right what is her facial
expressions
my my 10 year old son my 11 year old son
what is he trying to tell me what is he
actually speaking what is he interested
in what is he loving right now
and that's different than waiting for my
turn to give him advice well what'd you
tell the teacher well did you do your
homework
i know you got an a on that i'm way to
go what'd you get on the other exam
instead of just skipping everything i
can
listen to where he's coming from and
then i took that to work and started
listening to my employees in a different
way listening to my co-workers in a new
way
and just started teaching me how to
listen so start with your kids
just start tracking just start tracking
them if you've got
if you don't have young kids and you
have older kids
just start listening to them right start
in your head tracking them man he's just
throwing that ball back and forth man he
is making some great catches and then
you may
pop off with hey that was a great catch
man you're looking good
you're doing some good you're doing a
great job i saw your day at practice you
look good man
how was practice tell me about practice
and you start cultivating the practice
of listening and being with so
that's that's my uh two seconds for
today tracking it's awesome
all right let's get to the phones let's
go to my brother
radish in vancouver
canada radish i gotta just be obvious
man as a guy whose last name rhymes with
the lunch meat
i had the childhood man is your real
name radish or is that just what they
call you uh
as is what they call me well from one
fellow food nickname to the other it's
good to talk to you man
how are you i'm good thank you so much
for taking my call
you bet how can i help okay so i've been
listening
to the show for a while and one thing
i've noticed is quite a few of the
callers
are having some kind of struggle or
issue in like their marriage
so i'm calling because my girlfriend and
i have been dating for about five months
i i love her so much and i'm pretty sure
she's like the one for me
so i'm wondering what we can do now so
that
we are prepared to have like a strong
and connected and healthy
marriage in the future well good for you
man uh that's awesome that you are
thinking that way and i appreciate the
the uplifting call so i'm gonna start
your uplifting answer with a
negative are you ready okay there's no
such thing as the one
doesn't exist not real okay yeah yeah i
did you know i was gonna say that yeah i
know that dude is just
like the quickest way for me to
explain that i'm pretty sure i'm gonna
want to marry this girl that's your
heartburst when you when you're with her
okay so how old are you man
i'm 19. 19. all right and
tell me where you met her um
actually uh online um she actually lives
in
washington okay so she's about two hours
away from me
and it's been a difficult five months
since the borders closed i haven't
really been able to see her much
but we're
finding ways to connect online and
do different things so it's
been good so what
what has tipped the balance for you what
has made you say
you know what this is it man i've had 19
years of riding solo and it's time to
time to get a partner and head off into
the wild west wha
what is it about those last five months
what is it about her
that makes you think yep i'm done my
search is over
um well
i don't know i've thought about it a lot
and for me it's just
a whole lot of things seem to be coming
together well
like pick him up for me man yeah we
connect really well she kind of i'm
kind of a weird dude around here and a
lot of and it's hard to find people that
actually like
understand me yeah i can see that it's
like they're few and far between and
she's one of those people that actually
gets me
she's kind uh hard-working she's just
a wonderful person and it's somebody i
can see spending the rest of my life
with and so when you
so a being seen and heard for the first
time feels good doesn't it
yeah yeah and being valued for
the things that make you unique your
weird things i've got my plenty of weird
things
and um it feels good to be seen
right so yeah when you say hey
i think you're it what is what's her
response
uh she's pretty much in the same place i
am okay like we're pretty much on the
same page with it
and so fast forward what do you think
this looks like
and not in a not in a fantasy world or a
mythological world like walk me through
the next few months of your life
what is that going to look like well um
at the when we first started dating we
kind of made the decision that around
one year we would strongly consider if
this
was going to be like if we were going to
get married or if we were going to
end up going separate ways since we
don't want to date for
10 years and then did not go anywhere
really
so next few months is probably going to
be
just more getting to know her trying to
figure out some more stuff in my own
life and
make sure that i'm kind of on the right
track
and then go from there i guess i'm not
sure
all right so i'm gonna give you some
thoughts and some ideas
and what i'm not gonna do is say that
you're too young
and i'm not gonna say that you've only
known her for five months i'm not gonna
give you any of that traditional stuff
you're gonna get that from your friends
and your family
and from the internets and all that okay
so i'm not gonna give you those things
um 19 is young and i actually gave up a
full ride scholarship to one university
and went across the country to another
school because i met
a young girl when i was 18 and i wrapped
it up that was it for me i was done
and i ended up paying for school or for
a chunk of it
and um it didn't work out but i ended up
meeting the person i was gonna marry at
that same place and so
all i had to say is i've made some big
life decisions when i was your age based
on this feeling and this
i just know this is it and um so i'm not
even gonna judge that i'm going to say
man carry forward here's a couple of
things i want you to be
careful of and i want you to think
through okay
um thing number one is
there is a big difference between one
year and 10 years
and so i am really pushing back hard not
just with you but with
all of culture right now on this
obsession with an roi on friendship roi
meaning return on investment
you are my friend so that i can help you
can help me get a job
i am your friend because i'm networking
i want to be near you because you're
going to help me get where i want to go
um i want to have three friends that are
ahead of me and two friends that are
behind me dude we have lost the art
and the the spiritual connection of just
having people in our lives
just because and so i want you to focus
deeply not on a time limit if it's not a
year man we gotta call it because i
think that's
foolish and crazy my wife and i dated
five years we broke up a whole bunch of
times
okay any sort of artificial constraint
like that just becomes that an
artificial constraint and you're going
to find yourself making decisions
recklessly either
i'm not a hundred percent and so let's
just call it and you're gonna break up
with a great
what someone who may be a lifelong
friend or someone who's gonna be your
future
wife just because you hit a deadline and
i just am not a fan of those things
the other side of that is um
you're going to have to live in
proximity with each other
you're going to have to figure out a way
that you move to washington she moves to
vancouver that you all get in the same
area and get some physical proximity
over a sustained period of time where
you get to see how
there's some great research on disgust
and
relationships one of the biggest
predictors that a relationship's not
going to make it is with one of the
other people
one of the partners is disgusted by the
way they move their mouth
or like when they open their mouth if
there's like little saliva strings when
they open it or something like that
there's this disgust when they see their
mouth kelly's face is like yeah gosh
and james just passed out on the on the
on the board there
but there's something about you got to
see her okay
you've got to be in proximity she's got
to see you and it's got to see how you
all operate how you walk how you treat
people that
at the grocery store how you it's those
human things that you've got to see that
the internet just simply cannot give you
you can learn a lot about somebody but
it's generally a curated
experience online and there's nothing
that you can trade
for that connection and then here's the
final thing man
um
that one language that i'm in love
language is
is um i know you were you're just saying
hey that's the easiest way i can just
say man i'm all
i'm all in head over heels for this this
young lady
and that's all good but i want you to
always remember this
love is a choice and it's a decision
it's a thing you do every single day
so if you decide at some point in the
next
year two years whatever it is she is it
she's it and she decides that for you
i want you to know that that's not gonna
be a
um a
like there's not gonna be a music swell
and like you know there's not going to
be some james horner
like symphony playing up behind you and
suddenly you're going to stand taller
and you're going to have this romantic
that's just how it works you decide i'm
going to love you forever
and then you're going to wake up the
next day and say i'm gonna love you
forever and then
four months from then she's gonna get
like a real bad virus and be sick and be
thrown up and you're gonna wake up that
morning and say
i'm gonna love you forever and then
there's gonna be days that she just
walks in and takes your breath away
just stunning and you're gonna say i'm
gonna love you forever and then there's
gonna be days that she comes in and
you're like
i need you to leave because you are
making me angry and frustrated
and i am going to love you forever and
then there's going to be days that she
hits you in the head with a with a
wiffle ball back because you deserve it
and you're going to have to say i'm
going to love you forever
this is a daily decision every single
day for the rest of your life
and so as you sw as you more from these
feelings of desire i just want to be
with you i want to like
just be connected with you for the rest
of my life as that turns into
the day-to-day grind the day-to-day
safety as you learned
just each other's rhythms i want you to
then
focus on cultivating desire cultivating
being in love it's a
thing you're going to tell yourself
every day it's a thing you're going to
practice and that doesn't sound sexy and
they didn't talk about that in the
notebook
they didn't talk about that romeo and
juliet but it's the reality of living
with somebody
so all that to say 19 man you won the
lottery
good for you dude um you may just be
finding someone who sees you and loves
you for the first time and
high school sucks for 99.9 percent of
people because they have to pretend and
play and it's not real and it doesn't
feel right
um and so man i want to encourage you
lean in dude go for it at some point
you're gonna have to do your
goodwill hunting drive you're gonna have
to get an old crummy car and you're
gonna have to drive across the country
and
move to be next to her and you're gonna
have to figure out life that way
so brother radish from daloni baloney to
radish good for you
that's awesome um this brings me up to a
bigger question a couple of
not not a couple a lot of folks want to
talk about um oh by the way
go see a marriage counselor right i'm
looking down here at the email um you
all started doing some pre-marital
counseling some
relationship counseling it's a good at
your age
to begin to what are things i need to
look for in a marriage what are the
questions i need to ask in a
in a third party because some can often
walk you alongside and say
ask this question have you ever thought
about asking this and it just gives you
a new permission
so i got an email here from blake as my
wife and i have been discussing seeing a
marriage counselor to deal with some
small issues before they become big
issues
yes blake yes we are um that sounded
like
johnny carson's guy good for you blake
we are
new to our area and have no idea how to
find somebody
honestly pick up a phone book pick
up a or google it in your area marriage
counselors
in your area if you're at a local church
or at work ask somebody hey y'all don't
need
good good marriage counselors we're past
being embarrassed by that
every every couple should go see
somebody at some regular interval just
to check in
or have people in their life they can
check in with but just ask
and remember this the
most important thing the number one
thing
about getting well getting on the path
to wellness getting some good tools in
therapy and counseling
is the relationship with the therapist
and so you and your wife
pick one you go and you have a great
first session
and you really connect and this
therapist she gets you
or he gets you awesome go back you get
in the car
and your wife's like i love this
therapist he's incredible he hears us
and you say that dude is a
whack-a-doodle-do i'm not gonna see that
guy
can't stand them then you both go great
let's move on to the next one and then
you go find again
and then you go find again okay this
isn't a one-and-done deal
but honestly um don't be embarrassed
about it just ask just ask and if you
got to go to the phone book go to the
phone book if you got to go online look
for some online reviews
and go that away i think it's a good way
to handle it great question blake
um radish y'all go once you move and and
you're in the same vicinity then y'all
just agree
let's go see somebody and we can ask
some great questions talk about our past
and we can
begin to merge this thing all right
let's go to wendy in
atlanta georgia wendy good morning how
are you doing
i'm good how are you i'm all right i'm
all right so what can i do to help today
so my husband and i have children from
previous relationships
and a little over a year ago he had an
affair
with one of our children's moms
so i'm wondering kind of what are our
appropriate boundaries and how we kind
of move forward from that
there's a lot on that one man so
walk me through just some some of the
complexities how long have you
and your current husband been married uh
june will be five years
five years okay and then how many kids
did he bring to this
partnership two from two separate
relationships
okay so you a relationship number three
yes okay do you have any kids together
one okay so he brought in two kids
y'all made one and then how many kids
did you bring
one okay from one other relationship
yes all right so you have
four kids total
one you brought in one together and then
two he brought in from two different
people okay
so you have um one two
three four five different adults
navigating this relationship together
right
right plus um my daughter's
dad is married so we have we co-parent
well with her
with her stepmom so we have energy
okay all right so i don't know if you've
ever sat down and just
mapped this out like i'm doing right
here just to start this
that's a call it's a lot right it's a
family forest
we don't have a family tree yes you've
got
yes you've got a family forest here um
so
give me a sense of your demeanor
are you somebody that laughs a lot
through life are you somebody that holds
to control tightly like
tell me who you are oh man
i am a control freak at its finest
all right i am very one
ninety percent of the time so i like
things to be
stable and to go typically in the
direction that i
have planned for it to go
a little out of why i
get anxious about it so just taking a
stab at this
you spend a lot of your time anxious is
that right oh yeah
okay um and you after
a series of seasons being
highly anxious there's just seasons when
you want to lay in bed and not get out
of bed and just watch netflix is that
fair
that's accurate okay so tell me about
this guy that you married
um he's the total opposite he is very
laid back
so with the floor he doesn't get it
he's never really shown a temper about
anything
you know something starts to bother him
it has to be something pretty serious
um he is actually he's a detective so
a lot at work and then i think when he
comes home he doesn't really want to
deal with a lot at home too right so
he's he's a
he's a police detective he is
okay so i my dad was one so i grew up in
a house with the detective so i've
they're very unique extraordinary yet
unique individuals right so i got you on
that
so um so he
a couple years into your marriage was it
right when you were having a baby or
right around that season
uh no it was after okay probably she's
a little over one and a half okay i'm
gonna
i'll i'll call her a newborn until she's
about three before
your life becomes any semblance of
normal again okay
and folks with three-year-olds right now
are like they're not normal fair enough
so then he goes back to visit baby mama
of one or two or three of which he's got
three now
and they end up hooking up do they have
they just have a one-night stand or they
have a rekindled their relationship walk
me through what happened
um
hey talk directly into the phone okay
sorry yeah okay we were kind of at
a a little bit of a rough patch in our
marriage
i was really anxious about the
situations that we were going through
um just with his work and then with
having to co-parent with all of these
people so i went out of town
for an interview and while i was gone he
basically just he confided in her
told her lots of things that i had told
him out of
safety you know not really expecting any
of that to ever come out
and then he told her and then that led
to
an encounter just one time and then when
i came back home
um probably that following week
he he told me everything that happened
so he didn't try to keep it a secret
but that's kind of where we was he
remorseful and upset or did he just say
hey by the way
no he was remorseful he's tried really
hard to move past this
and work on our marriage and reassure me
this is not gonna happen again
sure um and so
that was a year ago and you stayed with
him so tell me what surfaced recently
that's making you wonder
how do we move on how do i how do i
reconcile this and keep going
well he's pretty adamant that
i have to make a decision
he wants things to be resolved between
me and his child's mother
and i'm a firm no
um she's not been remorseful about it
and as soon as she found out that i knew
it was well i need to tell her my side
of the story it was never
i'm sorry this happened this was a
mistake and it's been
a total not take responsibility
at all and that's just to me
i don't want to deal with it like i'm
going to therapy working on me
and if you're not making positive steps
to work on you
there's no benefit in this but i think
his biggest fear
is um that the child is going to
recognize that there is an issue there
because i don't have any interaction
with her whatsoever but i also don't
feel like i have to
he has a dad that takes care of him and
a mom
and when he's with us i love him so much
i take care of him
i don't allow my feelings for her to
impact how i
love him if that makes sense yeah
and so when what is the picture of this
mythical relationship your husband
envisions that you
and one of the other baby mamas has does
he want you all to hang out and go get
margaritas together
i mean what does he picture i think he
will i mean we talked about this friday
again
um it was basically you at least need to
acknowledge one another's existence
when you're around one another and you
know but prior to this happening
um we had a good relationship you know
we would go through things with the kids
all of us i mean we did birthday parties
together we were
unusual in that we could get along in a
healthy way
but then after that happened it was kind
of like well i trusted you
you broke this trust not just in a
little way but this was my
marriage right and you're not remorseful
so
i don't know i want to be okay
in the hate but that's it like i don't
want i don't want a friendship and i
think he
wants the friendship to be there so that
there's not an offer of tension that
is obviously there sure so
man i'm just gonna speak directly from
my heart is that okay
yeah that's done all right so number one
you married a guy
that has gotten three different women
pregnant and had three different kids by
three different moms
okay right so there should be no
surprise as to what you got tangled up
in
is that fair right yeah now
we all want us to believe that we're
going to be the one that
helps change somebody we all want to be
that person that i'm going to be so
desirable i'm gonna be so loved that
loving that this isn't gonna fill in the
blank and it did it happened to you that
sucks
right that doesn't give him an excuse to
cheat on you it doesn't give him excuse
to
go disclose intimate things to somebody
the hard part here is is that he's had
an intimate relationship with three
different people
right he's grown humans with three
different people
that's intimate moments and so what you
guys need to do is have a boundaries
conversation if you haven't already
and not a fight not a war but a
here's the things that i want to be ours
in this relationship
and normally that's things like kids and
home and not other women that's not
going to be your relationship because
you're going to have to share your home
with other people's kids
you're going to have to share your home
with other women and what i mean by
other women is there's going to be other
women coming to your house to pick up
kids you're going to drop kids off
that's just gonna be the nature of this
and as they get older
and you're navigating basketball games
and ymca stuff
it's just gonna be more and more and
more right that's the path you chose
when you married this guy doesn't mean
that it's not the right path i'm just
telling it's going to be more complex
and that leads me to part two here is
yeah
he violated your marriage covenant he
did
and that other lady violated your
marriage covenant
she did and you chose to stay
and you chose to continue to um
raise this baby this kid when when your
husband's got custody
which is part of being married to him
right and so that means you're going to
have to interact with her
does that mean you got to be friends no
does that mean you're going to call her
the next
one time something great happens no but
i do think that means you're
deciding to opt into a life where you've
got to be a civil adult
and your husband's right your kids are
going to learn
how you interact with people that you
are frustrated with or disagree with
they're going to learn that by watching
you
they don't have to know that hey dad
re-hooked up with baby mama again you
know what i mean
and that doesn't mean you have to be
okay with that what happened was wrong
it's not cool it was a violation of
everything about your marriage what i
don't want to see happen is
you continue you stay you forgive him
he's working his butt off to be right
he's
he is trying to change he's working hard
and
one year two years three years later
you're keep continuing to hang up
hang this over with him right because
then at some point it becomes your
challenge
either cut bait or be all back in but
you can't be all in
sort of with one foot and a couple of
toes
and that means being all in with this
guy means you're gonna have to interact
with her
if you ever sat down with her and just
said hey let's just talk
what would that conversation be like
um that's kind of that's what he wanted
but why won't you sit down with her and
say hey look we have
at least 15 years left of interacting
with each other
at a minimum and you're gonna be sitting
on one side of my husband and i'm going
to be sitting on the other side at this
kid's graduation
we're going to go to the same wedding
like we're in it now
what the hell like why in the world
would you hook up with my husband
like what what keeps that conversation
from happening
is it be just because she didn't run to
you and say i'm so sorry
no i mean it's just the pain that comes
with that
yeah i have
such a serious complex with um
abandonment and rejection that i work
with
and she speaks to those things because
she's angry at me too
like it's a constant attack on me as a
person
and i don't the idea of sitting down
with someone
and hearing those things just
it hurts i don't want to i don't want to
do that
i got you no it's hey that's brave that
you're saying that out loud and i
appreciate that
so here's a hard thing i'm gonna tell
you i'm gonna try to do it gently okay
um moving forward with that pain that
you have
and not addressing it for the next 15
years is going to be
really hard really hard it's gonna be
heavy
you can navigate it because you're tough
and you can navigate it because i think
your husband loves his kids
but it's gonna be really hard and
sitting down and having a one or two
time hard conversation is going to be
really hard
one of those leads to healing much much
sooner
one of those leads to putting those
bricks down much much sooner
and if you think about it from her eyes
you may be the woman that he left
her for right yeah
you may be both having the exact same
feelings about each other
about this one dude right and
there can be some common ground empathy
there is it gonna feel good
no i'm just trying to brighten my head
and be in your situation
dude you know what i mean i can't even
fathom it
but i'm trying to put myself in a
situation where i can look down
five years 10 years 15 years down the
road and say
this only ends in a train wreck this
just doesn't get better it just festers
and then at some point the kid turns 12
or 15 and starts asking questions and
there's just poison in the water
or i can bite down on my mouthpiece
this is a fighting reference i can bite
down on my mouthpiece and i can just
wait in there
and i can call her and say i'm tired of
hurting and i think you start that
conversation with
i have a fear of abandonment and
rejection and this was really hard on me
this is a year ago is
not getting better it's just getting
worse and
we've got to be grown-ups and solve this
for the sake of our babies
we got to solve this for the sake of
moving on and
i just don't see a way around that wendy
i don't see a way that you move forward
with any sort of peace in your life
in any sort of peace in your marriage
any sort of
wellness in your life that just the
constant cycle of inflammation is going
to make you
sicker it's going to make you your body
break down over time
all this is going to just continue to
happen because you've got this
heat in your life that's not going to go
away and i know you don't want to have
that conversation i cannot see a way
forward
a path towards healing without that
conversation
i don't think it's going to be easy it
might be actually
and it might be a moment where you all
end up weeping hard
and getting frustrated at each other and
crying and hugging
and then agreeing to be adults and even
if one of you has the courage to say
we're not gonna be best friends let's
just say that but we've got to do this
for the sake of
these kids i think there could be a lot
of healing there
can that happen i don't know man that
takes two super mature people
um that's the hope and here's the thing
i'm hoping for that
wendy i'm hoping that our country can do
that i'm hoping that people
on both sides of political i also can
sit down and say you have hurt me in
ways
you do things on the reg on a regular
basis you have a view of family you have
a view of money
you have a view of fill in the blank
that i think hurts me
but man not addressing this not being
adults not being real and not being
honest and just yelling and fighting and
avoiding
is just going to kick this and kick this
and kick this and we're going to teach
our kids how to do it
and we're going to teach their kids how
to do it until the whole thing falls
over
or we can
reach out with that first text message
wendy to this woman and say
it's been a year this is going to be a
hard conversation but i'd love just you
and me
to go have brunch one morning and
i'm going to be an adult and i hope you
will too and i know it's going to be a
heavy conversation but for the sake of
our kids can we just get together and
meet and talk
and um that's my challenge to you wendy
it's not gonna be easy i know
if you have that conversation um my gut
tells me it's gonna be a tough
brave healing conversation and i'd love
love love for you to call me back and
let me know how it goes
and you are not seeking validation you
are not seeking her forgiveness you are
not seeking her apology
you are seeking peace and you can know i
went first i went forward and i
heard out i listened i paid for the meal
and then we moved on so thank you so
much for your call wendy please let me
know how that conversation goes
um and i hope you will be continuing to
be brave and have that conversation
and tell your husband come on man stop
three kids three different moms stop
stop
stop okay
every detective out there needs to have
a therapist in their life because the
job is hard you all get to see things
you interact with people in
ugly and hard ways you do a trauma all
day long you gotta have somebody in your
life that's helping you heal
and i know y'all are smart and then
y'all are trained to walk into rooms and
see things that nobody else does
and you have to experience things that
nobody else does i know that because i
lived with it
that doesn't mean you're immune to being
a person
go get the help you need get the help
you need all right let's go to take one
more call let's go to heather in
knoxville
heather how are you
i'm doing well thanks so much for taking
my call you betcha thanks for calling
how can i help today
well um two days after christmas this
year
my husband had emergency surgery and
had a tumor about the size of a baseball
removed from his colony
i'm sorry yeah he was diagnosed with
stage three colon cancer and we have
three children
the youngest is 12 and he is autistic
and we are trying to navigate
how much we let him know about the
situation as far as how
dire it is okay because i i don't want
to
wreck his life but i also is
and we are fully expecting a complete
recovery
we have no reason to think that that
his debt is not going to completely
recover sure
but he's going to get very sick when
chemo starts in a couple of weeks and
we're just not sure
exactly how much we need to let him know
so give me a number one god bless you
dude i
i hate that for you that's not a
christmas anyone needed in 2020 for
god's sakes
and navigating well it was a 2020
christmas that let me just
geez man i know but still that just is
not great and i'm sorry that happened to
you
um how old are your other kids um 23
and 18. how are they don't laugh it
seemed like a good idea at the time
under the the 23 year old
my daughter has really
stepped up i spent the entire week in
the hospital
with my husband because half the floor
had been turned into a coveted ward and
so they were
extremely short-staffed because all they
had to pull their normal staff
to just do covet stuff so she really
what we really tried to do is make it
seem like a big slumber party so we had
friends that sent pizzas
they went to downstairs to my daughter's
apartment and played video games
and so she is she is handling things the
way she knows how to do which is
taking care of little details good for
her the 18 year old
we get to talk when we go out to walk
the dogs
and he expresses his concerns
in his oblique way right he's
he's managing as well as can be expected
keep i'll tell you what man you are a
saint and you just help
millions and millions of people across
the country with that one statement
you want to help your late teens early
20s kids
deal with challenges that show up when
grandma grandpa dies when mom and dad
get sick
get a dog and take walks every day and
it is the most healing thing yes all of
us don't get to move your body
you get to be in nature you get to have
a relationship and the same way little
kids
you play with them on the floor you just
walk with teenagers and they don't have
to make eye contact with you but they
will slowly start talking to you good
for you
all right so um give me a quick rundown
what's what's the functioning level of
of your 12 year old
high functioning medium he is
it's hard to say high functioning or low
functioning because he has his strengths
and his weaknesses
he has very good social skills great he
is
a great student he has
anxiety in a way that his brain
misinterprets ordinary signals
misfires and can send him into a panic
attack
which we didn't realize for years an
example was when he was
five and we went trick-or-treating and
the wind was blowing and he
freaked out and was screaming in the
middle of the street that we were all
going to die
right okay so he's got some hyper
sensitivity right
he does okay he does all right so
i 12 years old i'm gonna tell you a
story about a guy
he is a good friend of mine his name is
mark charney dr charney
and he is a of all things a
savant he's a theater he's the chair of
the theater and art department and dance
department at a university
and i watched had a ringside seat to
watching him
partner in the one of the most unique
things i've ever seen they partnered
with
the autism center of the university
and what they did was they connected
theater students to
these autistic college students and
the autistic college students some of
them were very high functioning some of
them
were not high functioning socially but
they were very good
right with with fact remembering facts
some were hypersensitive like the
sensations were
were over alarming right and what they
did was they worked with them and they
put on a play
and what was so magic about the play is
these young kids with autism did not
know how to properly perceive and feel
their own feelings
but they were able to learn this
character
is going to feel like this what does
that look like
make me a sad face make me a happy face
and over the arc of this play it's one
of the hardest i've ever wept watching
theater i'm going to get choked up here
talking about it
i watched these kids with autism inhabit
other people
because they were inhabiting the facts
of these other people
and part of the facts was learning these
emotions learning these feelings and
learning these pains and then when you
circled back the kids with autism said
i now have a new language for how i feel
and so what i would start with is
and you may say this it may not work
exactly with your kid i think you're
still going to be okay you're not going
to hurt anything
i would go find children's books
just go to amazon and get three or four
children's books
like they would tell a fifth grader or a
sixth grader
and there's gonna be a book called mommy
got cancer or daddy's really sick
and the way kids learn right is through
play and through
literary children's literature like that
and i would buy four or five of those
books
and then i would go through them and see
if any of those are going to identify
with your son
and then what i'd have him do is read
them to you and as you read them
i want you to speak out loud imagine
what this would feel like and so what
we're trying to do is to show
him into this story and then you're
going to give him pictures
because the book's going to give you
illustrated pictures
of a dad in a hospital of a mom in a
hospital maybe a dad losing his hair
and he's going to get a picture of it
what an autistic kid often struggles
with is
the outcome i don't i don't have they
don't have the the
sometimes they haven't learned or they
don't have the capacity to imagine or
picture
and so all the alarms set off at the
same time right
nicely and so what this is going to give
him is a picture of
and it may be if you want to do
something magic it may be a partnership
with your 23 year old kid and your 18
year old kid
and your 12 year old kid that y'all make
up some sort of play
and in your home and you're going to
perform and you can even tell them you
all have to do this play for me and your
dad
and through that it's going to talk
about somebody
overcoming something difficult the play
is going to be a wreck it won't be good
everyone will be dying laughing and
crying at the same time
but it will be a way to bring your
family together and on the back end of
this you'll never forget it
and then through that narrative when you
slowly start to see
where the the your your son's eyes widen
and he goes wow
that's the entry way to have this story
daddy might look like this because
daddy's really sick too and daddy
is one he's gonna get really skinny also
and
you're gonna see the the painful faces
in those books you're gonna see the
smiling faces in the book and the whole
time i want you to never let go of his
hand when you're reading these books
he's not going to probably realize it
but what you're doing is you are
telling that little oversensitive
amygdala
it's okay and i'm not saying that's
going this is going to heal at all
that's if i have a 12 year old son with
autism that's exactly where i start
and i've seen i saw a profound shift in
a way with
autistic young men and women that i had
never seen before
i know there's a lot of science autism
scientists that clued in on this
partnership and were all over it from a
research perspective because they saw an
awakening that
they had never seen before but where i'm
starting is with children's literature
through story through narrative and i'm
also giving him that connection because
i'm going to hold his hand through this
entire thing
and if we can get 18 year old brother to
sit on his bed on the other side
that's even better because i want him to
feel surrounded and
safe as we go through this hard hard
place
let me know how that goes and we will be
thinking about your husband
and um yeah we're going to expect it for
recovery he's going to be better he's
going to get there
and again thank you for being a mom who
loves
loves loves her kids and is doing what
she can to
ask the right questions and walk through
this together and you
heather make sure you got people in your
life that you can lean on because you're
gonna need a place to cry
you're gonna be propping up kids and
dogs and husband
and i want you to have a place where you
can get propped up too
thank you so much for that call all
right so as we wrap up the show
um i talked in a previous podcast about
the time i went to see
a concert i think it was the indigo
girls at the reiman or something some
80s group that i loved back in the day
or the 90s group
and warren treaty opened up and just
blew the show away right it just was a
rousing standing ovation at the ryman
auditorium here in nashville
i just i remember thinking whoa i've
seen that one or two other times and one
of them is when i went to see
my favorite rock band on planet earth
social distortion and they had this
little
um british singer oh singer songwriter
open up
had a band and his name was frank turner
and the show started with a bunch of
dudes and black shirts and big thick
black boots if you know social
distortion crowd and their arms crossed
furrowed brow and by the end of the show
the whole audience was singing along
this little guy from the uk won over
everyone i got obsessed with him his
name's frank turner
you can pick any album you can pick
almost any song there's a few songs that
aren't great but
he's just a savant he's extraordinary i
think he's the best one of the best
songwriters working today
this song is a song that my son and i
listened to when i drove him to work we
listen to it every day we sing it
together still to this day when we're
out doing stuff together
it's off the song positive songs for
negative people
some of you need this record in your
life by the way positive songs for
negative people
out in 2015 the song is called the next
storm and it goes like this
we had a difficult winter we had a rough
few months when the storms came
in off the coast it felt like everything
broke
on us at once it's easy enough to talk
about blitz spirit when you're not
holding the roof up and knee-deep in it
and the pictures and the papers got
ruined by the rain
and we wondered if they'd ever get dry
again but i don't want to spend the
whole of my life
indoors laying low waiting on the next
storm
i don't want to spend the whole of my
life inside i want to step
outside and face the sunshine i don't
care what the weather man is saying
because the last time i saw him he was
on his knees he was praying
and the preachers and the scientists got
soaked just the same
and we'd wondered if we'd ever get dry
again but i don't want to spend the
whole of my life indoors
laying low waiting on the next storm i
want to step
outside and face the sunshine
face it good folks face the sunshine
this has been the dr john dalona show